[Applause]
well hello
this is danielle dimartino booth and i'd
like to welcome you to another episode
of down
the middle today we have an
extraordinary guest
i cannot be any prouder to be speaking
with howard silverblatt
of standard and poor's uh he's been with
with s p
since 1977. uh
i consider him to be the s p 500
the index if you will and we have so
much that we're going to be able to
learn
so settle down grab a drink howard
thank you by the way for being here
appreciate all the time
we have something in common the two of
us we don't
have phds in economics we don't have
phds in finance we don't have phds in
anything so i'm curious to know
this is this sets you apart from your
siblings
you stopped after syracuse
university tell us why because you're
one of the most intelligent people i
know and i
don't flatter you especially but you're
one of the most
intelligent people i've ever met what
made you decide to
get out of school and start your career
as opposed to
following the same path as your siblings
and and going all the way through
a master's program or getting a phd yes
i i am the family dropout
uh whether you want to use my siblings
or you want to go to my parents
or other relatives uh i have no
phd at this point uh
most of uh high school and junior high
school
uh there was a lot of academics a lot of
pointing to academics
uh and growing up in the part of
brooklyn that i did
academics were important but it was also
the street and between the two
growing up uh i get more towards the
street
uh towards doing things and uh not as
much
much academic and discussions uh whether
it be
uh sports or whatever
and i kind of geared away when i got to
undergraduate
uh i i that point considered
potentially going farther uh we started
at that point you would go straight on
today after your undergraduate you know
you
usually wait a little while it's a
doctoral program
uh and i just decided that it was not
for me at that point and i needed to
take a break and if i wanted to go back
to academia
it would be uh fairly easy uh
my even when i was in school i remember
my my
my father still going to school working
on his second doctorate
at that point uh so
i i was kind of the outlaw uh and it was
amusing either
uh and it remains amusing uh to this
point
how many academics i do deal with and
how many uh dissertations i've worked
on with people getting uh you know abd's
to
to work on stuff they're a great way to
to get research
done with a nominal cost uh but
yeah i kind of shred away and i just
never went back
really to it i did a couple of courses
in different areas to see if i wanted to
take something
else up uh but didn't go back so
street smarts well a different way to
look at it uh yeah
uh academic would have taken much longer
streets were
much quicker gratification
you got out you got a job uh you worked
most of the day you partied most of the
night
tried to get in in the morning uh
and so it was perhaps short-sighted you
know in retrospect should i have gone
back to some other academics i i think
so
uh when i started out a lot of the
academics were a lot easier than they
are today
uh but the education i think i got by
actually working
hands-on uh compared to the uh
at that point more book approach
theoretical approach i i think really
did well
on my side and years later i've been
able to integrate the two
why standard and poor's well first of
all
what who were you before s p
uh i was a student uh s p took me fresh
and new
uh and uh i started i started there
uh may 7 may 17 1977 the s p was
under 100 under 100. so is berkshire
hathaway
and we're not talking about the baby one
uh so i started back then s p was a much
larger the whole whole working place for
financials was a much bigger pyramid
then
so you picked the house and you stayed
there for a couple years
uh potentially moving up but more likely
moving out
so you would get a a a good broad
education i mean i had to go through 10
k's 10
q's proxy statements registration
statements
i mean they had a physical library and
if you wanted to do something
you used micro fish uh which is no fun
uh even during tank uses you know the
earning seasons now i mean we got our
news
from a ticker system where you would get
the tape
literally cut it cut it you know and do
a story or something and start
researching something and it was out of
stock you might forward it to someone
else
so it's a different time um back then
you know the pyramids were much
wider at the bottom uh today they've
kind of moved in
uh back then people did stay at
companies for long times
pensions were prevalent uh there were no
401ks nothing was
portable uh if you work for ibm you've
got a dozen white shirts you stayed
there forever
you know again different times times
have totally changed the pyramid has
changed but i basically went to s p
to avoid broaden that uh
bottom line education get some practical
knowledge
on there something that i've learned
from you over the years
is that there's there's there's a church
and state there's a chinese wall
inside of s p there's there's the side
of the
business that you work in and then
there's another side
was it always like that
uh yes or no the the wall when i first
came was between
the equity which included stock analysts
as well as the indexes
and and the bond rating people corporate
and and municipal
uh and you were not allowed to even deal
with each other you couldn't be on the
same well at one point we were on the
same floor as one of the divisions and
they moved us a week later
uh if they only knew that i had dating
someone in the music god knows what they
would have done
but yeah there was always a separation
in that manner with ratings because
on an analytical side you are looking
what's the company's cash flow what's
the projections not the ones that
they're putting out but what are they
things gonna happen what's inside books
when they came in
uh for corporate rating they opened up
their books
they opened up everything they had their
cash flow their internals they have
plans and everything so the sides were
always
separate the index group back then was
extremely
small i think it was about five
full-time people
plus people they borrowed i was a
borrowed employee during
uh earnings season during uh at that
point which was
the reshuffling and some other items but
it was very
it was a very small item until the index
itself became
trading and at that point as the index
grew
it became a separation separation
currently is between those who analyze
and uh uh work on the attributes
and index as well as developing indexes
and those that maintain
it those will be the ones that apply the
rules those would be the ones that
take it and say okay this issue is
should be taken out this should be put
in what are the replacement issues
you know what's our goal on here to set
up the model
of the model both may work on it in
other words we want 27
as an illustration 27 of technology at
once
3.2 uh of energy and go down then try to
emulate because again the
purpose of the index is to emulate the
whole market
we if s p 500
semiconductors go up four percent and
the
market semiconductors go up two percent
we did not beat the market we didn't do
our job
so the separation between the two groups
those that pick it basically
and knows that uh with the analytics are
totally separate
uh and literally there is not just a
wall but
a different part of it you can't get
from one side into another
there's locked doors there's different
meeting rooms there's different
systems even internally if we were
having a
a video now and it was just between
people on one side as compared to the
other
you're going to different sites and if
it's together it's
a different site so it is extremely
important to keep because our business
uh relies on that
uh just as the ratings and separation
from the equity
you know 45 years ago did right right of
course
the the s p 500 itself is is that the
longest history
index in the country no
uh the dow goes back to 1896.
okay it's a lot more and that's just a
simple index you add them up
you divide it's very simple it's the
most commonly
uh quoted number most people know it if
you walk out on the street
not on wall street but if you just walk
out on main street somewhere and ask who
is in the day
most people could name a lot of issues
and if you name those issues
uh mcdonald's after they they would know
what they do
uh and it's very familiar and it's very
simple to understand
and divide the s p 500 is a lot more
complicated uh again
it's five it's 1927 is that right
well it actually goes back to 1923.
okay let me start actually here
the s p 500 as we know today started
trading in 1957
march at that point we combined four
uh four existing indices going back in
time
okay basically the three primaries okay
so these indices
backed up so we wanted to put the
industrials the transportation which we
actually call the railroads
and the utilities together to make the
which is what started trading in 1957 we
took these back indices
we did the math we didn't have to decide
who's going to go in where it's going to
be classified what this
stock price was it was just a matter of
adding so the 500 itself trades in 57
but some of the data depending upon what
you're using goes back to 1923 with the
most common
data being 1928 when you start getting
daily
uh when s p started in 1923
it was a weekly index there was no
calculators
you had an abacus uh and that was it
even when i went
i had log scales you had to look up
natural logarithms i know you don't want
to hear about algorithms
anymore but uh postcode era we put a lot
of things on log scales so
unfortunately we know what you're
talking about so
but uh so really it goes back to 1926
the pro forma from uh 2018 from 28 to 57
to perform though is actual
even though it didn't trade it because
it's three it's the indices actually
combined
put together what actually was there uh
but the trading is in 57 so yes that's
one of the older ones that uh that
exists
there are other railroad indices that go
back to the 1800s as it says
dow jones indices go has a dow jones
itself that goes back to 1896
uh on there so uh within the us
it is one it is one of the older ones
uh in existence so the dow jones was not
always part of the s
p family am i getting it right or wrong
that is correct
uh the uh part of the wall street
journal
and they still have a representation on
the determination of the committee to
make up the dow
but s p uh combined with the indices
only not dow jones which still exists in
the wall street journal of course
uh as well uh which is owned by fox
uh but s p combined the indices
component
and picked up the dow itself so now
it was smp indices it is now s
p dow jones indices uh and we do have
that
along with the uh the indices on there a
whole family of them both domestically
and internationally and when was that
when was that merger if you will
i was at seven years ago uh and we
came together uh and and it was pretty
good
i mean we did have many questions for
them uh
and it was amusing because after if you
call the apple
situation uh because the dow is weighted
uh by twice and before not this foot but
the price split
you know and i remember many times s p
sitting there wondering
what's down going to do with this yeah
and i never got a full answer to it but
obviously
apple did eventually split
price and smp did put it into the
dow jones uh averages uh but again the
price was a big
a big difficulty on that it's a price
weighted 30 issues
you do not want dominance uh on there
uh you know what and after the shift
with apple's weight went down so much
and technology went down to about
without 21 percent in the dow that was a
concern it was
said one day the next stage 21. it was
part of the
thinking show saying national on the
replacement issues
is you know i i can remember it was it
was probably just 18 months ago
that that you know prior to the boeing
situation that boeing alone could swing
the dow on any given
day when it was trading at its high
point
boeing and goldman before that uh yeah
there is a concern
about the pricing if something gets too
high or too low
it becomes almost irrelevant where uh a
stock on the higher ends and
selling for several hundred could go up
five percent in today's market that's
not in a reasonable
uh scenario get something on the bottom
at selling at let's say fifteen dollars
could drop a third and
the top overlaps it you know the the
amusing analogy
is that if you put berkshire hathaway
the actual
one the hundreds of thousands into the
dao uh regardless of who you take out
and the next day uh
all the other companies go under 2-0
but berkshire goes up ten percent the
dale's up that day
i love it yeah there's difficulties on
on on
that kind of as compared to the 500
everything has its pluses and minuses
so walk us through the construct then
and and paint us the differentiation
between
how the dow is constructed and how the s
p 500 is constructed
okay the dab was back forever 1896
uh when it was basically almost the only
methodology you can use is to take an
average you couldn't start doing market
capitalization weightings
uh you know you just couldn't trade like
that obviously
and couldn't deal with it so it was
sturdy and the intent was to
represent the top end of the us
markets uh not to totally emulate it but
to represent it and that's kind of
stayed true it's not the 30
largest companies and the weights
are relevant but the idea is to
represent
the us and it's an important industry in
that
most people understand they use it to
measure the economy
uh the s p 500 is totally different and
more of an investment tool
not as many people use the dow as an
investment tool it's 30
companies and i guess i should say that
over long periods of time
back to the 1920s the s p and the 500
pretty well
quality between themselves on any
short-term
loan it usually does not again because
of the weightings the s
p 500 is meant to fully emulate u.s
domestic market again that semiconductor
it's the markets two percent we need to
do two percent healthcare break it down
to biofarm so there's a
11 main sectors within the that we break
down
the index to and 153
sub industries so you've got to emulate
all these
on there and the idea is that you
compare the s p 500 to the broader
market so
if you're in the broader market and
you're in the s p you call it
very well for that reason investors
use that more as an investment tool you
can get into the general market
okay as compared to picking stock okay
or you can get a little bit less pass by
saying yes i'm in the s p
500 however i think technology is good
so there is a technology
sector within the s p 500 so i can go
long or short
on the 500 i can buy into energy and i
could weight them however i want
so the 500 plus all the iterations of it
permit individuals and money managers to
invest in the market
in any manner and form they want they
could be totally passive
put it aside that's the index i am doing
exactly how the market does
or they could start to slant the oil
even though
they're using the 500 they can use
different areas uh
and and and so the main difference is
what
investability at this point so it wasn't
always 11
main main sectors was it real
it was 10 real estate was taken out of
financials
it was a subgroup on there uh so we're
able to
just as we were in 1957 since real
estate existed
take that part out and do performance uh
so real estate was not always
in there uh recently we also had
telecommunications
which was a t and verizon redone and
we named communications uh
but the the groups in there could change
uh individual issues called
declassification and
every year we put out paperwork saying
potential changes in the gixx those are
global industrial classifications that's
what the 11 and the 153 are
exactly 411s uh so we
go through that and public comment and
could change uh typically that changes
are made in september
i should also add that msci
and s p do the gigs yes we are
competitors
yes we do not work on too many things
together we are definitely
rivals uh domestically and international
but we
do work together on the gixx
uh in order to maintain consistency
across the board and it's advantageous
for both groups
so s p dow jones copacetic one happy
family
on the indices side what about msci
msci is a competitive s p uh both
domestically and internationally uh but
there is
one group within msui and s p that
worked together
and that was on what's called gixx
global industry classification system
uh those are the 11 sectors there's
actually four levels coming down to 150
sub uh in hbo both s p
and msci work together to classify
each company on a company level not just
in the us
but globally so whether trades in the us
are not
this permits indices to uh more
consistency
between them uh it also permits better
control
uh on it it's actually a product out
there called
gixx direct uh which is jointly owned
with revenue sharing of course
uh so when we draw upon it whether it be
smp
or mscr or any of the products that use
those uh
ibm is always in the same group bp
always in the same group no matter who
it is if there is a change
is made simultaneously at the same point
one database uh right longer and
different
so that really helps both indices
uh should they have done it separately
at one point uh
and this is why i had theirs we had
hours and then back in 2000 2001 we got
together
as part of that group and we
worked out a methodology uh as well as a
review and a
revenue as much as of a business
decision on both sides as it was
an academic one there's that word
so speaking of differences uh in the
financial media when we see earnings
displayed how does what
we think of as earnings ibis factset
bloomberg
how does that differ from how you gauge
earnings significantly
during difficult times not much
otherwise uh it and we always seem to be
in difficult times
factset uh cap
iq ibis zax that's cool
what they do is they go out to the
analyst and when you're dealing with the
s p 500
your deal you're dealing with a lot of
coverage and they may ask 40 analysts
on there obviously if you go down to
small cap and you only find one
but they'll ask the 40 analysts what do
you think this company's going to make
and they'll give a number sometimes they
include things sometimes they don't
include things and then they'll take
them and put them through a test
throwing out the tail ends because again
you have 40 so you could throw one or
two of them out to have that
ability figuring out a mean median mode
standard deviation a whole bunch of
numbers that you could do with 40 or 45
companies on there
uh each one of those houses has their
own little niche
okay but basically if you compare them
they're relatively
close to each other as far as the
numbers going out
uh s p is different
s p uses methodology when you go over
and you ask
most analysts uh what they what
netflix might might be or apple uh
they're gonna typically exclude option
expense
okay but if you when you look at the
estimates on an older company
excuse the terminology ibm adp
uh they typically include it so there's
an inconsistency there that's how the
individual analyst because the analyst
doing ibm
is probably not the same one doing
netflix okay
so again the street estimate is based on
where the
covering analysts go s p i can't treat
apple any differently than netflix uh
and that goes for other things besides
options such as pensions
uh pensions on the street for att
verizon
typically are excluded because they are
enormous
yet for other companies like boeing
caterpillars typically put in there
okay so again when you get to s p we
have methodology
we always include pensions expense and
always include action whether you like
it or not there's a consistency there
okay and we measure it there we also
they're they're real i mean they're real
they'll feel and again both sides here
have
important uses and investors need to
know because if you're using the wrong
estimates or numbers and depending upon
when you're trading you could be making
a big mistake
again the uh the street estimates is
what the analysts think and if that
number
includes items doesn't it whatever it is
whether the analysts flip the coin
that's what the analysts are thinking
the houses did
when that number comes out at let's say
okay you've got to beat or not beat and
the aftermarket is going to move
at that point in time based on that it
may change if the ceo has a confidence
or something
but it's going to move so if you're a
short-term investor
you're playing that number you want what
the street thinks
right or wrong because that's what the
market is going to react to
on the short run the s p has the
consistency
okay the positive is that you can
compare
att ibm uh netflix it's all done on the
same methodology
it's like a piece of wood there you know
exactly what you're getting if you do
not like options
you can stick them out because we put
them in there if you do not like
pensions
you could strip them out and if you
wanted to say how do i get the first
call
okay find out which issues they're
adding each item in
and and moving over okay
we are more of methodology the traders
very often will use the street numbers
the analysts economists and strategists
who use the
s p numbers because they need the
consistency
right am i overpaying for the market
you know for 2021 at this point if so
how much
uh what's my return on equity what
what's my my book values to the bank
they need to be able to look back
sometimes say
this industry it's not just a 500 but
each one of those 153 groups
you know within the semiconductor what
is the r d amount what is the purchased
r d
what are these numbers on an actual
factual
number on there so the s p number very
often would be
different in harder times because the
street analysts exclude on the estimate
any unknown charges
so when the number comes in it is
excluded on our side
even if we didn't know about the charge
we're doing it in retrospect
you came in these are your september
numbers you had a charge and were taking
it
the easiest example is uh the old
tobacco
settlement which was a 25 after the 26th
we have a 25 year agreement signed by
many
companies they all signed the same piece
of paper yet the announcement street for
many of these companies excluded the
charge
and some included it same exact charge
same legal document it's just how it was
worded and
which one company was doing whether it
was more domestic or international
on the s p side we included it all again
maybe you didn't want to and you could
and they were sizable
and you could take them out so again but
in theory this was a one-time
26-year expense
from 25 years ago there's not a lot of
things that are still on there
right of course current assets but not
a settlement like that uh so again so
if you're short of term and you look at
the market those estimates are really
important and that's what you need to
use
if you are looking to see historically
how you fit in compare companies you're
doing a
a run to say you know give me companies
that
have certain characteristics you want
methodology
not how the analysts at that point in
time were thinking
okay and that could be stated on that
side on the index we do not
uh once the september quarter is over
which for us
is december 31 you could restate every
single number
to december 31 for your third quarter
and we will use december 31 documents
for the number okay if you go january 1
and make a change
we will not make it i don't care if
you're anyone it doesn't matter what the
story is here
december 31 the quarter's over this is
the number and it's marked historical
if we had a mistake we're human
we will go back and restate it and we
did in 1988
it was the last one it'll happen again
maybe not in my lifetime but mistakes
happen but we close
off the quarter we will not be stated
these other areas and other products
that dewy stated and that's useful you
want to look at the new pro forma for
spin-off
you know how to how did you united
technology the ultimate technology
uh work today without carrier uh
you know what's the stories i know so
those are important but on the index
basis
it's history pure history and it has to
be factual
so um i i think there's been a lot more
focus
on s p in 2020 than there's been
in many years because of one particular
car maker
uh so the burning question would be what
determines
companies that make it in into the index
and what determines companies that are
dropped out
of the index sure we're we're talking
about discretionary changes
not there's a deal coming in and you
have to take something out
right uh you obviously still have some
discretion on who you put in but
not on who's going out so discretionary
changes
basically go back to the intent and the
purpose of the index which is to
emulate u.s domestic common model
you have the index and you're looking at
technology
and it's 27 of the index and you feel
that
the market saying 30 which is not at
this point in time
anywhere near there especially after the
last two weeks
uh so you're looking at that at 27 30
it should be that means somewhere else
is
under represent is overrepresented you
know you might have four percent in
energy instead of two and a half
so you really need to keep these things
in check so you may not
put in and take out an issue just
totally on where it's market value is or
how it's been doing
okay you need to emulate so that's a
very important item
once you have those somewhat and said
and you're always looking forward
you've got a merger coming up in two
months you've got something from the mid
cap that's merging
the mid cap issue is going to probably
move up because it's getting so big
by the way most of the inserts
in recent years into the 500 is coming
from
the mid cap they move up they get too
high they're much higher
it creates a difficulty with mid cap
indexes
you know in portfolio managed because
they usually want to hold on to the
issue
because it's been going up right most of
it goes into here so
once we have the the sector and the
industry broken down
you know s p uh then you look at issues
that qualify so you have to have a list
of companies that potentially could go
in
we put out the on the web the
methodology for these
uh you mentioned not actually directly
but
tesla and one of the main uh issues on
there is
profitability on a gap generally except
the county principle
for 12 months not the operating not the
street estimates or the s
p modified one but actual gap and gap
is generally accepted accounting
principles these are the rules whether
you do it i do it or my my kid does it
it has to be the same number could it be
forwarding these numbers
of course uh but these are the numbers
projected by the ordinance
uh and tesla did turn positive that's
why i got a lot of
hype in there with the thinking that it
would go in
uh but qualifying on a preliminary basis
and again you go into more detail on it
but on uh the criteria does not put you
in there
it just means that you are on it
potentially on a list
when you come up you get more detail
into that and it has to fit into the
science
uh in tesla's case under the current
gift and classifications automotive as
compared to ford
and gm are you oh the question would
theoretically be are you represented
properly and you automotive
okay uh and or do you need more or do
you need less
uh and if you're properly represented
are there other issues that might be
better to take that in other words
they better perform with the market on
there so those are important items that
have to be looking at
tesla is an enormous issue uh if it was
at some point put in at the current or
back
when it became profitable it would have
been the largest issue ever
put in to the index not to say that that
is a difficulty it's not the dow
it's market weighted so that's not an
issue
it was the performance on there um
but there are certain criteria that the
companies have to make
profitability liquidity the ability to
trade because
again over 15 of the s p 500 is indexed
which means that if an issue goes in or
comes out
15 has to go and buy it whether it's the
best decision or the worst decision
okay so it needs liquidity on there
uh and that's also an important item in
the industry
looking back uh what are some of the
most memorable additions and what are
some of the most memorable
dropouts from the index and i mean
obviously we're going back
a ways but just just in your in your
mind's eye what what are some of
some of the most memorable moments
yahoo um
[Laughter]
uh and i'm still waiting for uh nasdaq
to send us a bottle of champagne which i
think they
they owe us because of that uh yahoo
back uh before it was put into the s p
500 was a high-flying issue obviously
uh but it wasn't owned by many
institutions something that institutions
learned very quickly
not to do uh but they were not owned by
a lot so when s p
gave notice a week's notice that they
are going to be putting it into the s
p 500 that stock shot up over the next
week
uh almost 50 percent oh my gosh but the
trades going across you know
when you used to see the trades you saw
40. those were not 30 40 boxes of shares
he saw a hundred shares going through at
a trade
institutions running to get them for mom
and pops who held them
or anyone so there was an enormous
amount of imbalance
fifty percent in a week okay for being
put into the index
bottom line is that s p had to put those
issues
uh that issue in at a much higher price
uh while some other indices that might
have had it in there
uh got to see their stock go their index
go all the way up
and a lot of them work under uh aun
assets under management so make more
money
on that uh on that so i i think it's
fair to say that we should have gotten a
bottle of champagne out of it
i love it uh so that's a but the
companies have
enormously learned from that uh and
keeping uh different ways to trade
obviously directed by the stock directly
the other options everything so
when issues come out uh within respect
to the 500 usually an ipo
you wait a year uh but when they come
out
they actually do uh uh look to buy some
of that or get some positions
on there uh when they go on the road
shows value up in that you know
an issue that is a question would you be
eligible for the s p 500 if so when do
you meet these criterias
uh and even when issues come out
of the index with the idea that maybe
they will come back at a later point in
time
it's on the road trip uh it comes up so
it's
very uh it issue
inclusions are very important so again
yahoo was the uh
the nightmare okay uh not that bad but
it was a lesson that
the whole street learned uh the other
memorable items obviously is when we
took out the s
p uh foreign issues
uh and uh at that point it was much
easier to tell a u.s company from a
foreign one
and things like sea gooms came out there
were seven issues so it became
a pure us play the s p 500
today uh the s p 500 still has what's
considered
all american companies but they may be
domiciled for tax
reasons abroad uh even though they're
considered
u.s companies and there's criteria to
determine you know what is and who is
not
a pure us company and therefore eligible
i i should note that about 43 percent of
s p
500 sales are purely abroad that means
they are produced
and they are sold abroad they could be
produced in canada sold in japan
but if they're from the u.s and sold the
board that's considered an export
but 43 percent of sales come from there
on the profitability side it's extremely
difficult
only about a third of the companies last
time we checked
we put any kind of profitability numbers
uh domestic
and that's on a pre-tax operating basis
we'd like with the definitions yeah tax
basis
uh so we don't have large handles on
individual companies
you know you can sometimes come down
especially technologies
they give you good retail companies give
you excellent foreign exposure numbers
um the tiffany's for example which
obviously is now dealing with merger
uh on their uh things like mcdonald's
which has enormous european presence
they will give you good numbers but
overall you don't get a good
net number and how is that 43 evolved
over time how how how much more
multinational
is corporate america significantly and
you've seen
changes uh uh part of this accounting
part of this wheel
technology has become a lot more as
chips have uh become
more abroad exports remember in the us
used to
be very few and even now the exports you
know our specialized equipment the
the old general electric things for the
nuclear power plants
uh which is not just the current case so
technology has increased significantly
oil is uh an energy is difficult because
they change the county methodologies
uh but they have basically increased on
their profit items
healthcare is another uh group that has
somewhat
stayed flat after going up and down but
again that's
a difficulty in international accounting
we have long
advocated that more uh information is
needed uh
the street would love it if you i can
build a matrix based on
your healthcare company you mine this
stuff out in iowa and you put it
together
in in the uk and then ship it to japan
and
put it back you you into download
we have again long advocated that you
need better
information on that companies do not
want to do because i and everyone else
on the street as well as you
will build a matrix and when the yen
goes up so much with a pound
does something or the or the euro you
build that in and you'll come up with a
list and it'll tell you
uh adjust your uh holdings in intel by
0.02
or something it'll be a black box
they'll instantaneously use the hedging
and everything on there
uh which might be nice for for
people with phds in mathematics
but the trader that's still using their
nose would not like it
but again the accounting is very poor on
that
and we have said that for years my first
day
at dlj
back in the day a gentleman by the name
of stan knobby who
sat behind warren buffett at columbia
business school sat
down the nba trainees and he said
uh you do not emerge from a bear market
on the s p until you have a single digit
price to earnings ratio and he told us
at the time that was
and even though in 2009 we got close
we we never really did get to a single
digit price to earnings ratio
take us back to 1981
and presumably stocks were hated
at that point but dirt dirt cheap
yeah again the p e ratio is important
historically we go back to 1936
sure takes it back although he
co-mingles some items
uh back to 18 1870s and 1890s he puts it
on his webpage by the way if anyone
wants to go
to yale yeah it's amazing it is good
data we i i use it on a regular basis
uh again it's not official but when
you're looking for things
uh yes going back to the eighties again
we're looking at a different time
inflation every time you're looking at
jimmy carty with tax rates
obviously with with reagan on the
situation the market
was a totally different item in there
also back there was
very important is who is doing the
trades
okay when i came when i opened up a
brokerage account in the late 70s i had
to wait
almost a week okay i had to bring down
everything you could think of
to to the broker to show them that you
know who i was what the bank is and
everything now i could start a brokerage
account
and lose my money in five minutes
okay back then it was more uh money
managers
pension funds never seen as a stabilizer
because they were going long-term
pensions were
still very important back then they are
still today but they were dying free to
define pensions
uh so that the market was different and
the technology
was totally different but the approach
was more fundamental
the p e ratio is there a yield do you
care about yield
if you've got a good p e what were the
all the ratios and the volumes
you're closer to a what today would be
considered a japanese approach of
asset conscious uh no items uh
so it was totally different you didn't
have the hype you didn't have
individuals you didn't
have robin hood you didn't have my son
going in and buying something because
it's nice today
as compared to tomorrow he's done well
but i would not like to uh
measure his risk factor risk awards
but uh so again back then it was
more a different market on there uh if
you were looking for a single pe today
you probably wouldn't want to buy it
because there'd be something wrong with
the company and we were still
over 20 pe over 21
20 21 earnings ejected earnings
okay and the 2022 numbers
you're still relatively high although
those estimates are very soft
back then the major difference was who
was controlling and buying the stock
everybody went to the same b school
whether they were domestic international
okay the us
dominated a lot more the u.s is now
about 53
of global markets back then it really
wasn't emerging
markets you know the development was
more european
on there so the us dominated so the u.s
pension funds money managers brokerage
houses
okay dominated the trades and their
approach was a lot more
statistical analytical uh
and long autumn longer term so there's
been a lot more ups
in your career than there have been
downs in the market but
but what was it like what what were
those days like
in in 1987 and how how did 87
differ from 2000 and 2008.
totally different um 87
it hit really quick and i should say
that i did not lose any money on that
monday
i was still on friday i had short-term
options in the money
yeah any calls everyone puts uh
43 000 on one trade anyway uh
the difference there was the imbalance
in the market
uh was the lack of control what would
and would not happen the uncertainty of
it
we have circuit breakers now we have
systems now
they did not exist back then uh
it was a pure bounce and the trades went
on the floor
you've been on the floor now but back
then it was crowded
okay now it's a section okay
it used to be five five full rooms and
now it's one
ah he crowded together i think they keep
six foot
apart so they're coping components but
with no difficulty
but back then the difficulty with the
trades the enormous
imbalance of it and the lack of
liquidity uh which also was a major
issue
of course in 2000 and a 2009 especially
with the legion brother situation but
back then you couldn't trade it quick
enough
and as the market dropped again even
before that monday it was concerned
and it was almost panics in there uh you
know when your phone call
you got over the weekend you hoped it
wasn't a margin uh for monday's 20
drop it was just uncontrollable
selling uh it could have actually gone
more
uh down there was some buying but if you
think the market's going down why are
you gonna
you know catch a falling knife this
bottom picks it up you don't get that
what's called uh can i say dead cat
downstairs
yes absolutely you know when you're even
going down you hit the bottom
you you pop up a little even if you're
gonna go down more but there's that
that trade in there you're more traders
back then that was short short-term but
it wasn't
the algorithms that were that did
although they were some primitive ones
uh but it was more the uh the trading
imbalance on there and
and it was mayhem i mean you've spoken
to people from the exchange
uh which would be a nice interview for
you to do
on there for the remaining man uh and
it it was a nightmare uh and the
uncertainty in the corporates
okay in the uh in the stock rooms
was enormous uh it was mayhem
uncontrollable
nothing like what you see statistically
now or that we've seen
uh and when you go to two then and you
go to 2009
remember it was dragged out over the
time period even right
before you had the bear from before you
had
the lehman it was the housing and the
memos coming out of everywhere
short-term problem no difficulties uh
we're going to get back on it
and and that will be it uh and actually
had gone
got worse the training got worse uh and
no equity dried up again liquidity
a major issue back then as it was now
with with covert
uh let a statement that uh
and and the liquidity was a major
issue for the 2008 2009 as the housing
went and that was
dragged down but a lot slower than the
crash itself okay uh
and totally different than let's say the
2000 2002 bear market
okay but the liquidity in 87 or
liquidity
in eight nine definitely the liquidity
in the cova situation alan greenspan in
used the words irrational exuberance uh
and then he did nothing they no it kept
going up
market kept going up he couldn't break
the requirements after that of course it
did
um but looking back to the late
1990s what were the red flags on your
screen
what were the tells well technology
uh just from an index point of view uh
went up
in 78 and 82 you know 75 to 85
each year that's the index we're not
talking about the high flyers
uh back then if you had an ipo and
technology obviously not an index issue
uh just buy it and sell it in a week you
know you put in for whatever
shares you'll get and whatever in a day
you take it yeah
and you just get rid of it i don't even
ask the name
what they do uh everything was on future
expectations
and yes you can draw some similarities
to our recovery now
but technology was the main item you did
not need sales
okay uh you did not need uh uh
profitability you needed hits and
a broad audience on there
that was a significant concern risk
totally turned uh higher across the
board and it was not that it was not
unknown i mean traders and and portfolio
managers had it i mean it was in there
the reports that you got in the stats
and then you know
how to risk reward scenarios changed
uh but you were on a a
big roller coaster going up and everyone
expected it to eventually go down
but not getting out until return and
when not everyone got out in time so
howard
let's shift gears here um talk to me
about
share buybacks they weren't always legal
uh but once companies were green lighted
by congress
uh how did that change the dynamic and
how did dividends play into that a year
ago we were talking about
record levels of share buybacks
obviously that's
that's dissipated to some extent but if
i follow your data correctly there are
still some big companies out there that
are still doing buybacks so
how have buybacks evolved
have they influenced dividends and what
can we expect going forward
viaducts did start to come more into bad
when the
regulations were changed for several
reasons companies uh
saw them as a cheap way to protect their
earnings they especially technology they
used
options a lot so they would give you an
option to buy the stock say
at 30 dollars a stock is now years later
if you exercise that option my eps go up
and
i'll go go down because my shares go up
so they'd go into the market they would
buy it for fifty dollars you give me the
thirty
it only cost me 20. uh then very quickly
after that uh companies figured out they
can
adjust their earnings okay and this is
why earnings per share and methodology
by that
need to be an undergraduate course not a
graduate course companies can go in
and by discretionary in that case it's
usually controlled
more by the board of directors than the
actual day-to-day people
uh because it's so much more expensive i
go in and i buy that full share at 50
okay and i put this share in my treasury
i don't retarget because i could always
use it later in some european countries
you have to
use it to lose it but they put it in the
treasury and my share count now goes
down
okay uh and at this point that means my
eps go up well
eps go up that means my pe is less i'm a
bargain
like me before now instead of having 18
pe i have 17.6
uh and we've seen significant buying
and adjusting because at one point in
and 2005 uh i and other companies
uh who put out messages to our analysts
when you're doing your estimates
make sure you have the correct shares
because buybacks we do so many of them
but what happened is the analysts used
the wrong shares and therefore they had
a lower eps they might have had the
right net
but they had the wrong eps so when that
number came across
the wire at four four o'clock i got a
beat what am i doing i'm buying
okay and then the cfo and the numbers
come out it's not a beat
it's the share count adjusting so
literally it was a major problem on
there
sec got involved with a whole bunch of
stuff but uh but buybacks became very
popular
uh at one point a quarter of the
companies
bought back enough to significantly
change their eps we believe that four
percent
is a significant amount because again
year over year you're comparing my pe
that means my pe has changed four
percent my ups has changed four percent
we did some statistical testing it came
out like 3.7 something
good enough make it four percent uh and
so we measure that
and that has gone up uh an average over
20 percent of the companies so one in
five companies you could typically pick
out
that have earnings at a minimum of four
percent
higher because of the eps so this is
impacted and remember those trades are
actual physical
trades because it's not option trades
and getting it's going to the floor
or the system putting in the trade so
you now have more buy-ins
my my stock is worth more with five
buyers than four doesn't change my stock
so buybacks became an enormous item it's
what uh in 70s and 80s stock sports were
you announce a big buyback your stock
goes up you've got support
it supports my stock it adds to my eps
is a win-win situation
what's happened now is that because
liquidity is
still remains the main issue companies
that
can buy back have high high cash flow
not just earnings but cash flow apples
microsoft
okay they are continuing and for that in
our last fourth quarter 82 83 percent
of the top 20 companies came to 82 83 of
all the buybacks
you either did them or didn't other
companies did not financials dropped
over 90 percent
even after warren went in about five uh
billion dollars in buybacks
uh financial went down because the fed
as you recall
came and made comments shock and dismay
within 24 hours
banks came out and said i will not buy
them for second quarter i
will not buy them for third quarter now
they're not calling them for fourth
quarter
so buybacks as you say went totally down
from the plus 200
to 88 billion last quarter this quarter
i'm looking for better
about a 101 billion
uh there is a potential small very small
uh for a buyback bonanza
uh if for some reason the market
perceived that buybacks would be taxed
significantly different next year go
back a couple of weeks to when a
pure biden win was in there and with
including potentially the senate the
house and and the white house
uh and the concern was that buybacks
next year would be
taxed differently companies couldn't do
it so it might have
ended up it doesn't seem the scenario
now but
the item was that use it always go get
them now
because you're doing the actually it's
gonna question the same with dividends
when tax rates went down
okay uh companies did not take a lot of
them did not pay q4
dividends they paid beginning of january
because you as a holder was getting more
getting more well
dividend tax is expected to totally
change next year
picture's not clear but if you go
through the agenda's there
it's going to uh increase so the
question
companies had to at least address
internally
i've got uh a dividend that's going to
be paid out
you know in january do i want to do it
in december
by the retailers use january of course
on there so do you want to pull it back
those do not see what's happening uh but
dividend
obviously and buybacks are connected
companies have so much to spend
covert of course totally changed
buybacks and dividends
uh companies cash flows cut off like a
light going out if you were
a uh a hotel
or or something a convention center or
travel
you got no cash flow and you had
enormous expenses
companies had to prioritize their self
okay
buybacks were the last thing typically
up to that point
you want to increase by actually go to
the board and then make a decision do i
want to do it or not i have plenty of
money
they could do whatever they want now
money liquidity was the main issue
uh because that buybacks took a far
back seat okay and we're seeing and we
see that in the numbers
dividends were a different situation
companies didn't want to
reduce their dividends poor signaling
those that had to
again going back to the hotels and going
back
to those that had their cash flow done
we saw an enormous
increase in suspensions not cuts but
totally shut off
42 companies in the s p 500 alone
suspended
their dividends not cut but suspended
them
because it was an immediate turn off of
cash flow
uh at this point did you're seeing
dividends
still continue we are going to see a
good year in dividends this year
considering everything
quarter one for dividends was a record
okay
second quarter since so many were
already declared came in very good
q3 went all the way down and q4 bottom
line for the year
uh actual pocket in your money in your
pocket on s p 500 dividends
one percent down given everything that's
a good number for actual dividends
uh but we're seeing in dividends is
fewer companies are increasing them
and this is within the 500 as well as
the u.s common domestic market
fewer increasing and the average
increase
okay for most companies average increase
is significantly been reduced to the
four percent area
from the eight and ten percent number
those that have good
cash flow and still have had the money
on the increasing highways well the
microsoft
billion and a half dollars more uh on
there so there are companies again that
have cash flow that are doing buybacks
and not doing dividends
but that's the minority in there all
dividends are holding their own okay
one percent down is not a bad number at
all
it's not the nine and a half percent we
were thinking of at the beginning of the
year and a lot of analysts made that ten
percent because you turn into a nice
double-digit number uh but
one percent considering where we stand
and where we look at things in march
is very good so dividends definitely a
positive item
especially with interest rates so low
now whether it be banks uh bonds
certificates there's nowhere to go if
you're looking for yield you have money
sitting on the side
you're not getting anything you have to
be there because you do not want to be
alternatives you don't want to be in the
market you don't want to be
wherever it is but you are not making
money on the slide so yields are one of
the few places to go
uh within the 500 yields of that 1.7 the
index
but for those issues paying it's 2.2
which is still
a very good yield however
of course there's risk there's always
risk
in any investment and it does no good to
get a good yield
and have your stock tank before we move
on i'm always fascinated when i get your
quarterly buyback email because apple
is immense in and of itself you said 82
of the buybacks were concentrated in 20
companies
what does apple alone represent
apple is at 17 18 billion dollars on
their condition
but this quarter that means it would
probably be 17 18
because i'm estimating about 101 billion
it is an enormous part of it
uh and again if they they have the cash
flow
obviously they have the cash resources
as you also know at the end
of q1 strangely enough companies set a
record for cash and equivalent
on their books uh not that they were
planning up
uh and the joke was that if we didn't
get covert
you know traders and investors started
complaining what he did with all that
money
uh and by the way since uh covent we've
seen an enormous
increase in equity offering offerings
which counter any kind of buybacks
and debt offerings companies are loading
up
on cash uh we're expecting another
record when we get all the
q3 number in we don't have them yet but
expecting it because cash
is the main item here liquidity is
important
apple has liquidity it is continuing a
lot of companies that have cash flow
are continuing with buybacks so we are
getting an enormous
top-heavy situation on their uh banks
and financials obviously
are doing nothing for q4 uh nothing's
been said about q1
but the bottom line is if it comes
between buybacks and dividends
they're sticking with dividends you're
talking about big
companies you're talking about
concentration passive investing
massive investing what is the influence
today
because i saw a report a few days ago
that said i think passive investing is
now 48
of assets under management on its way to
being half
uh and they're just comparing purely
mutual funds
to index funds in any event
uh you may recall before john uh before
john bogle passed away that he
publicly came out and wrote that if
if if passive investing was to become a
half of the market
theoretically in time that that would
actually not be
a positive development so what what's
your what's your views on this because
it's become
an enormous force it's become a topic as
well
at what point do certain investors or a
certain type of investment whether it be
an index or an individual
vessel a fund that gets too big and can
continue on impact
outside i think your 48 number which i
haven't seen probably includes what we
call emulators
uh and just to give you an idea of what
an emulator is they might buy as an
example
70 of the s p 500 directly indirectly
instruments however they do it and then
with the remaining 30
attempt to beat the index they could do
that with 10 20
20 shares even once i mean a small
portfolio
but the bottom line is that they're not
going to be that far away from the s p
500 so i think that 48
might be a lot of those inmates and we
believe i don't have documentation
because if i knew you were emulating the
index i would charge you a licensing fee
uh we believe that that could be more
than the 15 that's licensed
uh but to go to your passive situation
on there
uh the passive uh
within the the s p 500 emulates the us
domestic market so these people are
actually buying
the us market and if s p is doing its
job
probably we are moving with them
therefore
they still are investing but they're not
stock picking okay on there
is it too big on there uh that's a
legitimate question considering uh
sizes of everything uh but at this point
it does not
uh when you get everybody moving in and
out of a stock at
initial point it could be but even when
we
put issues in and out of the index the
impact is not what it was
when you and i started in the business
it's not that enormous
just buy it or just sell it it's going
in there very often it's going into
another fund
uh or it's already anticipated because
again going into 500 most of the
companies win
the mid cap least the largest reason to
go in there and when they
come out they may be going into a mid
cap so you're switching funds
so the impact of the concentration is
not as large
any uh on a short term basis uh
as you would think uh all more put
people putting their money
in to passive investments
yes uh is that because the index is so
great and fantastic and marvelous
i think it would more be that you're
more concerned with picking out the
actual index
stocks and also uh investors that we see
as well as money managers use the index
as one component so this is and you just
like as an emulator
this this is the market and that's where
i'm going to go so i know i'm going to
be near the market
but i think tech again will do better
over so i will go short or wrong i think
apple is totally underpriced i'm going
to overweight
i am going to underweight microsoft and
again just as
an example or i think tesla is a great
stock it's not me that's i'm buying it
so again you see a lot of those and you
see a lot of
other funds being used in there dividend
funds as a matter of fact preferred
funds are still very popular
for income i don't give as much of a tax
advantage but
there's set amounts uh on duration so
yes
the passive has been growing i don't see
it as a
situation currently it is definitely
being reviewed everywhere because it's
an issue
and needs to be worked out like it or
not so that's one
aspect of today's market the other that
so many people talk about is
concentration
the fang stocks has there ever been a
time
in your career that you've seen this
level of concentration
in just a handful of names as we as we
do today
no that's from 77 but if you go to the
early 60s you do see
higher concentrations of the top 10 for
example in the uh
high 20s we hit over 29 at one point
here
the top 10 which is enormous it is
spread out over that at one point
uh pre-breakup uh ibm
and att were close to 12 by themselves
ibm was supposed to come out with a new
product something about
personal computers or something like
that uh so they will
back up and att was before the breakup
so we've seen situations for issues on
there
okay uh but these top ten we have not
seen since the 60s it was not
that much there it appears that in the
30s it also was
uh but we did not the marks were totally
different and the share counts
different situations capitalization
float which we use now
uh but you really can't find a current
scenario
where you get that much of an
overweighting
on the top the positive item on it is
that it's not
just the market value they are adding
the earnings
to it uh not all equally obviously
amazon
uh but when you look at apple's
profitability uh whether you played it
or not each quarter
you know it is there microsoft cash flow
these companies are there
uh so it's not the way you've got some
of the concentration at the end of
1999 uh when also as microsoft didn't
have as much income or loosened
technologies
or if you go back a couple months before
that uh aol if you call those
uh so again we're seeing a concentration
that is something to to know and see
what it is with and without it
you know we are love 10 without the top
flyers we are not uh we were up a tiny
tick
which in and of itself even if you
exclude us and say okay yeah today we
will tick up
given all the economic data currently
not saying what we're going to be next
month whenever ensures the world
but right now that's a pretty good
number so yes the concentration is at
record levels
let's go into my wheelhouse for a minute
uh the
quantitative easing era monetary policy
you were around when volcker didn't care
about the markets
and it was a much different kind of a
relationship between wall street
and and the federal reserve how is that
influence
in your view historically speaking
changed and
more importantly can the fed ever stop
we've been told in the last few months
that qe
is now official tool in the toolbox and
that they will be using it
on a regular basis and i think the
market has
priced in that they're never ever going
to exit
one of biden's potentials was to dig up
off the barons
who vocal worked london by the way uh
when he was head of new york
the market is addicted
to the fed okay we were addicted to some
degree to buybacks but the liquidity
issue and
the product is in there i don't think
you can make a good
case that if they didn't do what they
did
to that jeremy we would have these kind
of markets
i think would have been a lot more
damage out there significant damage
whether you're measured by unemployment
companies
whatever it is so pretty positive could
they have done better
historians will go back and say yes or
no but we have gotten addicted to that
and the fed has uh signals that this
will continue for a while
so the market has this built into every
spreadsheet
uh no one's looking for the uh the
10-year to go back to 16
jimmy carter times now you know 1.6
maybe you'll see
on a couple of longer term ones not even
next year or the year after
uh so yes the market is basing these in
uh that liquidity is there financing is
is in there
uh and that you will buy anything uh
out there that is broadly considered
fixed income
regardless of how it's classified 40
years of low interest rates
every once in a while in history it's
rare but every once in a while
the market the market takes off and does
its own bidding
i mean theoretically there's a bond
vigilante left somewhere there i mean
they can't all be dead what would
interest rates
being taken out of the control of the
fed long
long maturity what would rising interest
rates how would that factor into
the market today because there's a lot
of chat about
the potential for for the
bond market to divorce itself
from monetary policy that's that's just
the the chatter on the street that we're
going to be in a rising interest rate
regime that we're going to have
fiscal spending as far as the eye can
see and that
at some point uh we we're that the fed's
gonna lose control
obviously higher deficits uh and yes
inflation will eventually come back uh
not to the hopefully the uh carter times
but you know to where it's
well above that uh anywhere near two
percent range
on but as far as the market goes okay
right now
we've got short term you've got the
numbers so you so you assume that
going forward one of the scenarios one
of the branches
much higher spending uh potentially
balling through their creation
on there the expense on the on
corporations
again we're looking from the market
perspective
okay higher interest rates but we are so
far down compared to where it was five
or ten years ago
these numbers are significantly down
even with higher
debt okay i mean a lot of members of
what when companies
trying to refinance they've got to buy
bonds that are a much higher
you know calling them in on there you
haven't seen that since the 80s
you know jenny mays and those
so yes higher interest rates will hurt
the companies but also put money back if
we get a general increase
all those investors mentioned going into
cds and there's
a lot of money sitting on the side does
not go into stock
they're going to get at least some more
income in there corporations have enough
sufficient cash on hand access to
liquidity
and in general cash flow cash flow is
not what it was
okay earnings are not what they want
especially when you do a cash flow
remember a lot of these charges
were non-cash it's a paper charge it's
going to change your depreciation it's
going to change your gap numbers
but the cash flow is different on there
okay
so the companies on next several years
even if we get
higher interest expense uh
we're going to have more stimulus and
they should more than compensate for
that
from a market point of view again uh
inflation farther down higher interest
rates down there
how you pay for the deficit uh how how
those bonds that are maturing
okay if all of a sudden it's not point
something but
you know much higher numbers very valid
and if you were to do this for a 20
30 year it's an enormous amount i think
you put it on your top list
of concerns for the economy uh working
at the debt levels whether you want to
do it as a percentage of gpp
gdp whether you want to do prop whatever
you want to do
average cost of capital to the
government
with the debt going up as well expected
to go up more
is going to be a problem uh shorter term
is a different situation and the market
obviously is a different
interpretation a lot of people who have
been investing for a long time the
howard marks of the worlds
they're sitting on record cash piles
right now and separately i went out and
i asked
most my buddies in your city if you if
you got to ask howard silverblack
one question what would it be and again
schiller was out in the new york times
dr schiller was out in the new york
times with an op-ed
a few weeks ago it made a lot of waves
he basically said
you know stocks are really overvalued he
hasn't said that for years and years he
hasn't said that since 1999.
but he came out and he said that so the
the burning
question on everybody's mind again after
a good
long run in stocks is what is the tail
risk
what could put us into a situation where
where all of these
predictions are going to come true that
we're going into a lower
longer period of low stock market
returns
unlike what we've become accustomed to
uh the continuation of the covet
situation obviously some companies are
adjusting
and and it's working for them and the
markets are adjusting to that
just as when i walk on the streets the
restaurants are adjusting
you know with eagles and things like
that
but if you get a prolonged period of
significant change
consumer spendings which was used to be
rule of thumb 70
okay and now everyone thinks it's higher
because capital expenditure was gone up
slightly
has not kept up uh so going
forward uh what would hurt the market is
a lack of expenditures by consumers and
uh covet would continue that you're not
getting travel back yet
again this would be the scenario travel
does not come back the way it is
so all those industries all those people
that had jobs
okay are not going back the hotels are a
fracture the airlines are a fraction
the manufacturing is reduced so covered
remains a major item getting it under
control
not necessarily with a cure but a
treatment and a way to monitor it moving
the death penalty to ge i had it it was
a terrible two weeks
is is different so colvin is the current
mean situation
that could produce a drive it would
probably
increase those that are doing well and
make even a bigger pyramid
the uh uh we said 29 now that 20
under 27 we would see that go up you
would see
the higher end making it more the
easy analogy i have and have not you
know in the market
those that survived it and those that
don't eventually the market and the
economy comes back into equilibrium
there's a lot of pain in there on there
and that's what could do it again we are
paying
over 20 pe or 2021. if i told you the tu
is
20 now you would think you know under
normal situations
you would say that's very high you know
it should be in the mid teens
i'm looking ahead the end of 2021
and we are over 20. so we are paying a
lot now for what we believe
is going to be tomorrow and the market
is
all about expectations it's what you
expect to come in
just like similar to the elections what
you expected
okay and that's where we reallocate
after when you get reality
the old idea of buying anticipation
selling reality
okay so yes the market's anticipating a
lot now
so a downturn is somewhere going to have
to
make itself felt okay and we
dropped over 30 in that uh
february 19th to march 23rd time period
that's
really quick to go down i mean it's not
the 20 we had on
in october of 87 a single day but we
dropped down significantly
and so if the market does not see and
perceive
that we are getting back to where we are
where we think
they're gonna be okay we're not talking
about a quarter
you know okay moving it from q two three
to q
four both into twenty twenty one but now
we're into twenty two
you know maybe you're gonna have to see
some
adjustments to that you know
just so much you're gonna discount back
so covet would be the situation i have
one final
burning question for you howard um
and i mean just take your time think
about it
the mets or the yankees you must be
joking jack are you kidding me
[Laughter]
if you get back to new york you're
buying
uh i am a young i am buying
i know that i know this howard a whole
routine don't
don't even mess with me it's hard to be
a mech man also
uh those people that are are really
dedicated uh yankee people come in and
out
but it is hard to be a mech fan um
and they are they do have dedicated
people there
well howard uh i am going to be the
first to say that i hope the next time
uh you and i are sitting across from
each other and going through a long form
interview like this that we are doing it
in person so um take good care
take good care of new york and thank you
so much for all of your time today we
really really
appreciate it this is danielle martino
booth
and this is down the middle thank you
for your time today